Traduttore: Sofia Ramundo
Revisore: Maria Pia Lanfranchi
(Applausi)
Buongiorno, io oggi vi parlerò
di come un errore
mi ha cambiato la vita,
letteralmente, in positivo.
Io lavoro al CERN di Ginevra,
il CERN di Ginevra
è la più grossa organizzazione di fisica
fondamentale che esista nel mondo,
composto all'inizio da 12 stati membri,
adesso siamo in 22,
quindi tutta l'Europa e in più
c'è anche Israele,
fondato, tra gli altri,
dall'italiano, Edoardo Amaldi,
proprio con lo scopo
di scienza per la pace.
Noi facciamo fisica fondamentale.
Pensate, siamo circa 5.000 persone
che lavorano in maniera permanente
al CERN di Ginevra:
3.000 dipendenti e 2.000 in altro titolo,
ma 13.000 scienziati, ingegneri, tecnici
da tutto il mondo vengono
a fare esperimenti.
Ogni giorno ci sono circa 7- 8.000 persone
che si affollano, si affannano
sul sito, per fare questa cittadella
della scienza, qualcuno ci dorme anche,
ci sta dei periodi,
ci passa il weekend eccetera.
Ma per fare che cosa?
Cos'è la scienza e lo scopo
per cui noi ci siamo?
Noi vogliamo capire
come siamo evoluti dal Big Bang.
Il Big Bang, che tutti sappiamo
è l'inizio della nostra storia,
non è solo un'esplosione.
Contiene un sacco di questioni,
un sacco di domande.
Per capire come siamo arrivati noi
a esserci oggi, al today.
Per esempio,
una delle prime questioni è come mai
la materia e antimateria che,
per le nostre teorie,
e anche per quello che conosciamo,
è tutta uguale,
è perfettamente simmetrica,
invece all'inizio c'è stata una sottile
asimmetria, quasi subdola,
che ha permesso a noi di esistere,
alla materia di vincere la battaglia
sull'antimateria e di evolvere fino a qui,
oggi, noi, adesso.
Un'altra ancora quasi non dico
più importante, sono tutte importanti,
ma sottile questione,
è un'altra rottura di simmetria,
vedete la fisica com'è bella,
è fatta di simmetrie
ma le cose interessanti
sono quando si rompono.
Una rottura di simmetria ha permesso
alle particelle di avere massa,
subito all'inizio del Big Bang,
le particelle non avevano massa,
io non avrei i miei 90 kg,
neanche i vostri,
però è successo qualcosa
che si chiama Bosone di Higgs,
di cui poi ritorneremo a parlare
e di cui forse avete già sentito parlare,
che ha permesso a noi tutti
di avere massa.
Quindi noi cerchiamo di rispondere
a queste domande fondamentali,
c'è chi ci risponde guardando verso
l'infinitamente grande,
con i grandi telescopi, sono i nostri
amici e colleghi astrofisici o cosmologi,
noi invece andiamo verso
l'infinitamente piccolo,
perché l'universo, all'inizio,
era infinitamente piccolo,
14 miliardi di anni fa, quando è nato.
E andando verso l'infinitamente piccolo,
di che cosa abbiamo bisogno?
Di un super microscopio.
Pensate, l'LHC, quei tubi blu
lì che vedete,
è un'enorme macchina che sta
a 100 metri sotto terra,
è lunga 27 chilometri,
quindi è circa quasi tre volte
il tunnel del Monte Bianco
che ho fatto ieri per venire fino a qui,
pieno di alta tecnologia
per fare che cosa?
Per generare una luce finissima,
per poter vedere i quark,
una luce che è un miliardesimo di volte
più piccola dell'atomo.
Prendiamo l'atomo, facciamo
un miliardesimo di volte più piccolo,
riusciamo a vedere i quark,
eppure ci sembrano sempre
delle particelle puntuali, senza massa.
Tutto questo,
questa altissima tecnologia,
per generare questa nuova luce finissima:
è la luce della meccanica quantistica.
Ma vedere non basta avere la luce,
se qui adesso l'elettricista spegnesse,
non mi vede, ma anche con la luce,
ahimè, se qualcuno non avesse gli occhi,
non mi vedrebbe.
Per vedere non basta la supermacchina.
Ecco, intanto vedete qui in alto
il tracciato giallo,
27 chilometri in questa piana bellissima
di Ginevra, dove c'è il lago Lemano,
dove c'è il Monte Bianco,
dove c'è il nostro LHC,
vedete lì di nuovo i tubi blu,
ma ci sono quattro grandi occhi,
due sono molto noti, sono Atlas
e CMS, sono i due di lato,
sono molto famosi e sono gli occhi
che hanno visto letteralmente
il Bosone di Higgs, di cui poi parleremo.
E noi speriamo che questi occhi
vedano oltre il Bosone di Higgs,
perché il Bosone di Higgs,
bello com'è, ha chiuso un libro
ma deve aprirne un altro.
Oggi noi sappiamo che il Bosone
di Higgs spiega solo il 5%
di quello che esiste nel mondo.
Molto poco, bisogna andare più in là.
È un po' la nostra summa teologica
ma rischia di diventare la nostra gabbia,
la nostra prigione,
noi vogliamo andare al di là.
L'altro rivelatore, ad esempio, LHCb,
quello che vedete in alto,
è un rivelatore che cerca di studiare
proprio la sottile differenza
tra materia e antimateria, che ha permesso
a noi di esistere all'inizio.
Ci stiamo riuscendo? Per ora no,
ve lo dico, ma siamo lì per imparare,
per apprendere appunto.
E torniamo all'LHC, pensate,
27 chilometri di alta tecnologia:
ci sono voluti circa 25 anni
per essere costruito,
ed è una super macchina basata
sulla superconduttività.
Non posso spiegarvi che cos'è, questo
sarebbe tutto un altro TEDx appunto,
però è un fenomeno meraviglioso. Pensate:
un filo elettrico che avete a casa vostra,
che porta 5-10 ampere,
con la superconduttività porta
1000, 10.000 ampere
e senza consumare,
senza pagare
la bolletta elettrica all'Enel.
Senza consumare,
è superconduttivo appunto, non dissipa,
però per fare questo ha bisogno
di una cosa speciale,
il cosiddetto superfreddo, ha bisogno
di frigo speciali che lo portino
a -270° di temperatura.
E quindi questo ha bisogno di un termos
speciale, che è il tubo blu.
Letteralmente, la sua peculiarità,
il magnete, questi supermagneti
che guidano le particelle sono dentro,
il tubo blu, che tra l'altro sapete,
i primi tubi blu sono stati fatti
qui vicino, proprio a Schio
che credo sia a 30 chilometri
qui da Vicenza,
quando ero giovane venivo a lavorarci.
Perché son stato giovane anch'io
e quando ero giovane mi sono innamorato
di questo fenomeno
della superconduttività,
c'ho cominciato a lavorare
e poi dal 2008 ho cominciato a lavorare
da professore dell'Università di Milano
all'LHC, alle prime idee eccetera,
e quindi sono venuto diverse volte
qui a Schio.
E per farvi vedere,
questo è il primo magnete,
quel tubo blu lì è stato costruito
qui a Schio, quindi la pelle attorno,
non la parte di magnete,
questo qua è il primo magnete
superconduttore che abbiamo fatto per LHC,
sulla base di questo
è stato approvato il progetto.
Pensate, dalla costruzione di questo,
nel '94, ci sono voluti altri 15 anni
prima che l'LHC partisse, quindi 25 anni
in totale, 10 anni di (incomprensibile)
e poi 15 anni di costruzione.
Tutto con molta tecnologia italiana,
gran parte dell'LHC è stato costruito
tra Genova, Schio e altre parti d'Italia.
Benissimo, siamo partiti, poi nel 2001
mi hanno chiamato per mia fortuna
al CERN di Ginevra per dirigere proprio
la costruzione dell'apparato magnetico.
Pensate, da solo vale più della metà
del costo della macchina,
che era allora circa 3 miliardi,
negli anni 2000.
Quindi ha avuto un certo successo,
nel 2006 abbiamo completato
la costruzione dei magneti
e mi dicono: "ma resta,
fai anche l'interconnessione tra magneti,
l'integrazione, mettili assieme".
Vedete, è una cosa molto importante
metterli assieme, non è difficile,
vedete la complessità
del mettere assieme due magneti,
vedete lì quei due
super tecnici che lo fanno.
Diciamo, tecnicamente è meno difficile
che fare il magnete,
ma è il regno della complessità,
perché è il regno delle interfacce.
Differenti team, differenti tecnologie
devono essere messi assieme,
niente di difficile, ma la gestione
della complessità è diversa.
Mi ricordo ancora, 8 settembre 2008,
la partenza, successo mondiale,
Google ci dedicò il simbolo,
allora Google non cambiava il simbolo
ogni giorno come fa adesso,
era sempre e solo quello,
in rarissime occasioni lo cambiò,
ce lo dedicò quel giorno,
perché ci furono 250 giornalisti
che vennero al CERN, successo mondiale,
eccetera.
Due giorni dopo, nella mia Piacenza,
sono piacentino di origine,
ricevo il premio, forse un po' immeritato,
come cittadino illustre.
In conclusione, torno
e dico ai miei ragazzi, a mia moglie:
"Godiamocelo questo premio,
non si sa mai",
pensate, nove giorni dopo
è successo l'incredibile,
è successo che la macchina si ferma.
Perché? Perché ci fu un grave guasto
proprio nell'interconnessione.
Non ve la sto a fare lunga,
anche questo fece la prima sulle pagine
dei giornali e della televisione:
un'interconnessione bruciò,
tutta l'energia magnetica
dentro questi magneti superconduttori
bruciarono due magneti,
ma prese 50 magneti,
questi magneti pesano 30 tonnellate,
sono come un tir carico,
e li mandò uno contro l'altro.
Un disastro incredibile,
perché non solo bruciarono i due magneti
dell' interconnessione,
ma ci fu appunto una serie
di danni collaterali incredibili.
Qualcuno cominciò a pensare:
"Ci vogliono due o tre anni per riparare,
forse non è riparabile, la macchina
ha una debolezza intrinseca".
Si scatenò il panico, questo è l'errore.
Colpa mia, colpa tua?
Quando succedono queste cose,
il problema di tutti è un po' smarcarsi,
è umano, colpa mia, colpa tua,
è un problema di interfacce.
(Applausi)
È un po' come quando in Italia succede
qualcosa, un'alluvione,
per l'amor del cielo, bisogna perseguire
chi ha fatto degli errori,
però a volte fin troppo, bisogna
innanzitutto rimboccarsi le maniche.
Ed è quello che ho fatto, vedendo
quello che è successo,
ma se andiamo avanti così
non finisce più.
Mi sono detto:
"Ma chi è responsabile,
sono io", anche se non ero lì
a fare la cosa.
È successo un errore,
chi doveva controllare sull'errore?
Chi doveva mettere in atto
tutte le procedure
per intercettare l'errore?
Sono io, sono il responsabile.
E quindi ho chiamato la gente e ho detto:
"Ragazzi, non preoccupatevi, sono il capo
della parte magnetica, il responsabile
sono io, responsabilità oggettiva
innanzitutto, ma anche magari
di non aver pensato a tutte le cose.
Adesso ripariamo,
poi se devo andare via, vado via."
Ci sarà un nuovo management,
veniva un nuovo management al CERN,
e via, e da lì ci siamo dati da fare.
Questo ha liberato le energie,
perché anziché mettersi,
proviamo a smarcarci,
a trovare un way-out,
e tutti si sono messi assieme.
E lì ho capito veramente dove il noi
non è il contrario dell'io,
è l'esaltazione dell'io, nel noi
l'io trova il suo vero vantaggio.
(Applausi)
Grazie.
Ma lasciatemi finire, perché qui
sono draconiani con i tempi.
Qui non posso permettermi gli applausi.
Vi dicevo, andando così,
l'abbiamo riparato in solamente un anno
e un anno dopo, fine del 2009,
l'acceleratore ha funzionato,
umilmente abbiamo capito
che quell'errore lì era un sintomo
di una debolezza strutturale
che aveva il nostro acceleratore.
L'abbiamo riparato su tutto,
guardate l'anello,
la parte rossa sono i 700 metri
letteralmente disgraziati, rovinati,
ma abbiamo riparato la parte gialla,
nera, lo vedete lì in alto a sinistra,
un po' tutta la macchina,
in più siamo ripartiti lentamente,
pensando anche: "Ma se succede ancora
qualcosa di simile, come evitare i danni?"
Perché vedete, quello che abbiamo capito
è che noi eravamo arroganti,
non succederà mai, invece dobbiamo dire:
"No, succederà".
Sbagliare è umano, come ci dicevano già
i nostri padri latini, sbagliare è umano.
Se metti in conto l'errore, metti anche
le barriere che impediscono all'errore
di propagarsi o di generare troppi danni.
Umilmente siamo partiti a basso regime
con la macchina,
non subito a tutto gas,
come pensavamo di fare all'inizio,
e abbiamo avuto il nostro reward,
il nostro premio,
perché abbiamo potuto, pensate,
solo due anni dopo,
pensavamo di metterci molto di più,
abbiamo potuto chiamare
il professor Higgs,
lo vedete lì, Peter Higgs
professore inglese, scozzese,
Peter Higgs, in un affollatissimo
auditorium del CERN,
abbiamo potuto fargli vedere,
a lui e a tutto il mondo,
che avevamo trovato il suo Bosone,
il mitico Bosone.
Ora sappiamo perché noi tutti abbiamo
una massa, che non è proprio da poco.
Persino un giornale come l'Economist,
normalmente non molto amico della scienza,
ci ha dedicato la copertina.
La nostra Fabiola Gianotti,
che adesso tutti conoscete
come capa del CERN,
direttrice del CERN,
allora era responsabile
dell'esperimento ATLAS,
quindi lei annunciò il Bosone di Higgs,
diventò una delle cinque persone
di copertina del Times di quell'anno.
Viene dalla mia Università,
quindi siamo orgogliosissimi di questo.
E immediatamente fu dato il Premio Nobel
disponibile al Professor Higgs,
e al Professor Englert
immediatamente l'anno dopo,
il primo Premio Nobel disponibile.
Quindi una storia a lieto fine
perché abbiamo trovato questo,
molto di più, perché per me
è stata davvero a lieto fine?
Cosa ci ho guadagnato?
Perché alla fine, tutto facciamo
per guadagnarci.
Anche un santo, anche uno che dà la vita,
lo fa per un bene superiore.
Uno quando fa una cosa deve guadagnarci,
è un principio di fisica,
il principio di minima energia:
tutto si fa per guadagnare,
la Natura fa questo,
quindi quando uno fa un atto di altruismo,
è perché pensa di guadagnare
un vero tesoro, più importante
di quello che dà via.
E io cosa c'ho guadagnato?
Vi dico, c'ho guadagnato
professionalmente,
guadagnando ancora di più
in carisma e autorevolezza:
la gente mi segue. Il nuovo management
anziché mandarmi via
m'ha dato, dopo aver riparato,
un incarico più importante.
Oggi dirigo il nuovo progetto bandiera
del CERN, l'ho proposto nel 2010
e si chiama "LHC ad alta luminosità".
Sono lì con un incarico più importante
con cui finirò la carriera,
e in più
c'ho guadagnato umanamente:
ho imparato che prendersi la colpa,
la cosa che nessuno vuole,
scusate se lo dico, la colpa
è un po' come la cacca,
appena è fuori nessuno la vuole,
la vuole più toccare,
è letteralmente così.
(Applausi)
Invece, se uno parte dall'idea:
ma io sono limitato,
farò l'errore, lo mette in conto,
può partire, può farlo diventare positivo.
L'errore, lungi dall'essere
una cosa che ti schiaccia,
può diventare come un segnale
stradale che ti indica dove andare,
e andare meglio.
Difatti vi dicevo, abbiamo capito
che quell'errore lì
era segno di una debolezza strutturale
che aveva la macchina
che sarebbe stato molto più grave
se si rivelava dopo.
E l'abbiamo riparata,
ma l'abbiamo riparata addirittura
dopo aver trovato il Bosone di Higgs,
completamente,
l'abbiamo finita di riparare nel 2015,
quindi c'abbiamo messo 5 anni,
completamente.
Ma ho guadagnato
anche umanamente:
con mia moglie
abbiamo due figli,
il più piccolo, Pietro, mi ha detto
che andava male a scuola.
Fisico, io sono un po' pretenzioso,
professore universitario,
ho tanti difetti, non solo questi,
ognuno ha i suoi difetti,
e quindi mi arrabbiavo con lui,
perché mi sembrava che non si impegnasse,
come spesso capita ai ragazzi, ai maschi.
E io lo bastonavo,
ma poi ho capito,
ho detto: "Ma ragazzi,
se il mio capo mi bastonasse,
anziché aiutarmi
a riparare l'errore?"
e da lì ho capito
che uno sguardo diverso, positivo,
non nel senso
che l'errore non va riconosciuto,
l'errore è l'errore,
lo sbaglio è lo sbaglio,
ma lo sbaglio è lì per indicarti
come migliorare,
lo sguardo che serve per il figlio,
ho capito che è lo sguardo
che serve verso il collega,
non è diverso,
io è questo che ho guadagnato.
Che un guadagno morale non è diverso
da un guadagno professionale.
Se è vero per me come persona,
dev'essere vero per me anche come fisico.
Io è questo che vorrei trasmettere,
l'errore,
anzi non bisogna mai
farci schiacciare dagli sbagli,
ma capire che l'errore è lì
per indicarti che insieme,
non da solo,
non solo con la tua volontà,
ma con uno sguardo insieme,
la comunità non è il contrario dell'io,
è l'esaltazione dell'io,
e quindi insieme si può andare avanti
e l'errore anziché essere una barriera,
può diventare il sasso
che anziché essere d'inciampo,
metti il piede e vai ancora più avanti.
Grazie per l'attenzione.
(Applausi)